[拍手]
皆さんこんにちは
秦真由美ですあーもう緊張でも心臓が
バクバクしていますがどうぞ温かい目で
よろしくお願いします
では今日の私が用意した話は13歳の私に
向けてというテーマになります
13歳の私はいつもこの質問を考えてまし
たなぜ学校に行くのか皆さんも学生の時
こんなこと考えたことあると思います
この質問の答えはたくさんあると思います
私の場合は友達が言ってるからとか親が
行きなさいというからで他にも一般的に
言われてるのは学校に行く理由は勉強する
ため
友達を作るためそして今部活だったり授業
を通して新しい知識や世界を知って
豊かな大人になるためそのために私たちは
学校に行くんだってなんとなくみんなの
共有している意識があるかなというふうに
思います
では皆さん
想像してみてくださいもしあなたに子供が
いるとしたら皆さんがもう親ですねでその
子供が13歳ぐらいの子供が今日学校行き
たくない
休みたいなって言いました
皆さんなんて答えますか
ダメしっかり来なさい」って言いますか
それとも優しいあなたはいいよ休んで
いいよって言いますかどうでしょう
私はまあ1日休んでいいかなとか明日は
行ってねって言うかなと思います
ではこの質問がもう学校休み始めて1週間
経った後にまた言われたらどうします今日
も休んでいいよってなかなか言いづらく
ありませんか
先ほど
学校に行く理由を考えましたで学校に
やっぱり毎日行ってほしい
理由っていうのは学校に行かなくなると
なんか大変なことが起こりそうっていう
不安が私たちの中にあるからですどうして
この不安が生まれるかっていうとこの学校
に行くべき理由を私たちは感覚的に学校に
行かなくなるとこれらができなくなる」
っていう風に考えてしまいます例えば学校
に行かなくなると勉強に追いつけなくなっ
てしまう
友達と会えなくなっちゃうから
疎遠になってしまうかもしれないそして
一人きりでふさぎ込みそして仕事にいい
仕事に
就くことができないそんな考えがあります
そしてこのだから学校に行くのが大変だ
学校に行かなかったら大変なんだって
私たちは思いますでこの大変だっていう
気持ちが加速すると不安でいっぱい
いっぱいになるとこんな言葉が出てくるん
です
学校に行かないで大人になると
社会で通用しない
常識がなくなってしまう
大人になって嫌なことがあった時
頑張れない人になってしまう
コミュニケーション
能力が落ちてしまうんじゃないかそんな
呪いの言葉が今の日本日常の中ではあり
ます
実は私は中学3年間学校に行ってません
でしたなので私はこの言葉にすごく苦しみ
ました
自分で自分のことを信じられませんでした
し周りも私のことをきっと怠け者だと見
てるのかもしれないって不安になった
気持ちもありました
これが私の通知表です中学生の時の通知表
です見えますか数字が0って並んでますね
もう13歳の私もこの通知表もらった時
ショックでした皆さんもきっとこの通知表
もらったらショックになるんじゃないかな
と思います
もう本当に自分に疲れつけられた評価この
0っていう数字が自分の未来がどうなるん
だろうというもうとてつもない不安に
襲われました
今の日本には
約24万人24万人の小中学生が学校に
行っていないと言われています
昔の私と同じようにきっとこの日本のどこ
かで私の未来はどうなるんだろう学校に
行かなかったらどうなるのって不安に思っ
てる人がたくさんいると思いますなので
今日はこの場を借りてこの私が今までどう
いう風に学校に行かなかった私大人になっ
てきたかっていうのを一つの具体例として
紹介したいと思います
昔の私がその不安だった理由の一つとして
身近にこう昔学校行けなかったけど大人に
なって充実した日々送ってるそんな具体例
を知らなかったっていうことが不安の原因
でしたなので皆さんもぜひ皆さんの周りに
学校に行ってない方がいらしたら今日の私
の話を思い出していただけると嬉しいです
はいもうね学校に行かなくても私は明るい
未来があるんだよというのを今日話せたら
なというふうに思います
では私の経験過去について中学生の私です
中学1年生の夏に私は
起立性調節障害という病気で学校に行け
なくなりました
学校に行かなくても家で勉強すればいいん
じゃないかっていう考えもあると思うん
ですが私は病気だったためそれもできず
ベッドの上で
ぼーっと過ごす日々を送っていました
そして
高校生時代
大成高校に入学しましたすいません
説明をされてた部分がありました病気に
ついてです今日の起立性調節障害という
病気は手術だったり何か特別な薬を与える
ことでたちまち良くなる
良くなるような病気ではありません
回復するまでに時間がかかる病気という風
に言われています一般的に言われているの
が大人になる頃には治るであろうそんな
時間のかかる病気なんですなので私は中学
3年間も学校に1日も行くこともなく
終えて高校生になりました
中学を卒業し始めた頃少しずつ体調も良く
なっていたので高校に進学したいなとは
思っていたのですがまだ毎日通えるほど
元気ではなかったそして3年間勉強して
なかったのでたとえ高校受験
合格できたとしてもクラスの勉強について
いけないそんな理由があって私はこの単位
制高校に入学しました
そしてこの体制高校のメリットというのは
週に2回か3回に学校に行くだけでそして
中学の勉強を振り返りをしながら勉強する
ことはできるそんな学校のシステムになっ
ています
でデメリットとしては私が中学の時憧れて
いた学校行事体育祭だったり
修学旅行だったりそういうものがないって
いうのがありました
中学生の高校生になったばかりの私は中学
3年間私は病気で青春がなかった高校でも
ないのかってちょっと落ち込んだりもし
ましたでも気持ちを切り替えて私は大学生
になってから体が元気になって大人になっ
てから精神を作ろうそしてそのためには
素敵な大学生ライフを送りたいと思い大学
受験を決意しました
やはり
病気では勉強していなかった私にとって
要するに体は高校1年生頭脳は小学校6年
生逆転コナン君のそんな状態だった私に
とってはもう退学受験の
壁はすごくハードルが高かったです
なので自分でも大学行きたいけど不安に
なる時もありましたそういう時は自分に
ポジティブな声かけをよくしていました私
はできるんだよだったり不安では落ち着か
せプレッシャーを感じるそんな時は
ダイヤマンドって
プレッシャーからできるんだよってそんな
いろんな自分を元気にする言葉を投げかけ
続けましたそして自分を信じてできる
できると毎日足を足を進めると
結果的にはい私は第一志望の国際キリスト
教大学に現役で合格することができました
そして私はこの経験からもう本当に自分を
信じてよかったって
学びましたこの写真私です大学1年生の
初日の時の写真です
キャンバスは飛び跳ねていますはいすごい
嬉しかったんですよねはいなので大学生に
入ってから自分を信じて挑戦することで
めっちゃ素晴らしいんだなそういう風に
気づいたので私はそれをそのまま自分に
活かしていきましたでどういうことかって
言うと
突然なんですけど私
プリンセスが大好きなんです
プリンセスお姫様ってやつですね特に
ディズニープリンセスが大好きで
彼女たちのようになりたいと私は思ってた
んですなのでこんなドレスあの卒業記念に
高校の卒業記念に来たりとかしてました
プリンセスって言ったらドレスもそうです
けど
ティアラもありますよねわかります
ティアラでも
ティアラってなんか私の中で特別なもので
お金でこうなんか買うのは違うかもしれ
ない
したらお金以外の方法で手に入れる方法は
ないか考えましたそして私が考えついた
解決方法はこちらですミスコンテストに
出る方もちろんねミスコンです私出たり他
にもあるんですよでも
ティアラが欲しかったそれも大きな一つの
理由でしたそしてこれが出た第1回の私の
メスコンテスト
果たして結果は皆さん話の流れ読んじゃっ
てるかもしれないですね
残念でした
初めて何もわからない中挑戦したには奮闘
したんですけれども
ティアラは手に入れることはできません
でした
そして
負けずに自分を信じて挑戦することが大事
って言ってるんだから2回目やりましょう
よって私も挑戦しました
そして
1回目の
屈辱をもう
晴らすように頑張ってましたさあ結果は
こちらもランキング外でした
2回も破れるとさすがにもうこの時点で2
年ぐらいかかってるので私ってできるのか
なーとか
悩んだりもしましたそれでもやっぱり
ティアラ欲しいなっていう気持ちが強かっ
たのでもう一度3回目のミスコンテストに
はい出場しました123を見ていくと
なんかレベル上がっててませんねだんだん
綺麗になってませんか
私も自分を調べてどんな風にしたら自分が
魅力的に見えるかコントコンテストで求め
られる自信のある気品のある姿そして綺麗
なウォーキングいろんなこと勉強して
練習して挑みましたそしてもうね3度目の
正直ということではい残念でした
ランキング概念になってしまいました
自分もちょっと心の中で心がションって
あのなりました
3回目もダメだったあんなにもが3年も4
年も頑張ったのにできなかっ
たで3回も出場したのにできてない
そうするとだんだん自分も自分のことまた
疑い始めて周りもどういうふうに私を見
てるんだろうっていうふうに思いました
だって皆さん想像してください
身の回りに3回もミスコンテスト出てる人
いてねずっと抽選してたら何やってるん
だって思いませんかあの私もその自分自身
でもそう思ってていやー私に何回出るんだ
勘違いしてると思われてるんじゃないかと
かすごい不安な気持ちになりました本当に
折れそうになった時に
昔の私が支えたんですいや人生一度きり
楽しもうよとあんなに病気で頑張って
悔しい思いしたのに今楽しく生きないで
どうするんだやりたいことやろうよそして
はい4回目のコンテストにも出場しました
そして結果は
はいあのプロフィールにもあった通り
グランプリを受賞し
念願のティアラ今日持ってきましたはいを
受賞しましたそしてはい私の欲しかった
はいこちらダラン
ティアラを自分の欲しかったものを手に
入れることができました
向かいます優しいありがとうございます
そうですね私のティアラは象徴するものは
もう周りの声だったり目線だったり自分が
自分を疑う声それは聞かなくていいそして
自分を信じて少しずつ少しずつできること
から
毎日コツコツ進むことでこの
欲しいもの
未来は開けるんだそういうのを確信しまし
た
私がこの今日の経験を皆様にお伝えする
ことで言いたいことが学校とかが大人に
なる素敵な大人になる方法を教えるので
なく私たちの考え方次第ということです
学校以外でもこうやって大人になってから
自分の青春を作り出すことができます
そして私が大事だなと思うのはやっぱり
自分の好きなことだったりちょっと苦手な
ことそういうことに興味を持って何がやり
たいかっていうことを見つけて進むことだ
と思っています
今日の私の話は
昔の私がきっと聞きたかっただろうなぁと
いうふうな話です
今の私は昔の私が会いたかった私です
昔の私はきっと
困難な時にでも大丈夫だよ進んでごらん」
って自分もっと信じていいんだよって
そんな
背中を押すような一言が欲しかったんだと
思いますなので今日は皆さんに私からその
言葉を伝えたいと思います皆さんぜひやり
たいことがあったらぜひ自分を信じて
挑戦してみてくださいそしたら本当にいい
こと起きますはいご清聴ありがとうござい
ました
[拍手]